[Music]
and welcome to Hannity tonight we are at
the end of what has been a decisive week
of wins for president Donald Trump in
the span of just a few short days the
president delivered the most powerful
State of the Union address the address I
have witnessed in my adult lifetime and
oh yeah the impeachment witch-hunt
totally implodes the president
exonerated forever
penny Pelosi well her months of this
long charade culminating what was a
pathetic nationally-televised
petulant temper tantrum look at your
screen this is what the modern radical
Democratic Party has achieved in three
plus years with their non-stop rage
resistance their witch hunts conspiracy
theories and lies a few ripped up pieces
of paper and that's it now penny Pelosi
well she's not exactly a master
strategist you can see and we witnessed
this week she is an angry bitter
mumbling bumbling sore loser and likely
will in fact go down in history as the
worst speaker of house that we have ever
seen one thing is a certainty tonight we
could say this her days as Speaker are
now numbered and once again we were
right all along and the media mob war as
usual wrong again raising the hopes the
expectations of their dwindling
audiences yet again only to disappoint
them yet again with more fake news now
of course this impeachment charade the
Schumer ship sham show would end in
utter failure but they were raising the
expectations of their well small
audience viewers another huge loser in
all of this well that would be quid and
pro and quo Joe and a zero experience on
hunter would be in paid millions now
despite the attempted hypocritical
double standard cover up by the
Democrats and their allies and the media
mob we on this program were correct we
told you the truth Joe hunter guess what
they engaged in nothing short of what
was a shady sleazy and yeah we believe
criminal potentially illegal behavior in
the country of Ukraine we were also
correct that Ukraine interfered in the
2016 elections to help Hillary Clinton
don't believe me
let's look at the January 11 2017
investigative report in Politico and by
the way that conclusion also came about
election interference by Ukraine
separate and apart from Russia from a
Ukrainian Court just like when we were
correct in reporting that high-ranking
government officials abused their power
and committed faiza abuse we were right
that the Trump campaign was illegally
spied on by members of an opposing party
at the height of the election with deep
state operatives behind almost all of it
we were correct that Hillary Clinton yep
Russian interference
she bought and paid for the dirty
unverifiable Russian dossier we now know
full of a pack of lies in other words it
was Russian propaganda used by the
Democrats even the New York Times
finally got the picture and they pointed
out we now reason to believe as they
said it was likely Russian
disinformation all along make no mistake
we were right about the deep state which
was chock-full of Trump hating Obama
holdovers two of these anti Trump
bureaucrats will remove from the White
House thankfully earlier today both
lieutenant colonel Alexander bin Minh
and his twin brother they were escorted
out of the White House complex good for
the president and you might remember
Lieutenant Colonel Binh Minh was
trashing the president during his
testimony in the house and rebuked the
administration's policy in Ukraine
mr. bin Minh you want to be in charge of
foreign policy why don't you try and run
for president then we find out his twin
brother was assigned to the office that
was vetting publications from government
employees by John Bolton's book although
at this time we don't have the evidence
that he handled the Bolton book but I
have my suspicions it is clear President
Trump is draining the swamp and this is
what it looks like and for good reason
we have been right every step of the way
the media mob has been wrong nothing we
have reported has even remotely been
disproven we now have the inspector
general that's horowitz's report
vindicating the reporting we've done for
almost three straight years on this
program doesn't seem to matter to the
radical Democratic Party and their
co-conspirators state-run media mob but
that doesn't matter to the radical dem
party either in any way they don't care
about the truth they all live in this
bubble they never question their own
narratives they never listened to
opposing viewpoints most of them don't
even probably have conservative friends
they hate this show but thank you for
making us number one we want to live up
to your expectations every day and
telling you the truth matters to us
getting the facts matters to us but to
our well colleagues in the media they
don't seem to care and we know that they
frequently mistake their own far-left
opinions as undisputed facts and
actually say in their own heads they're
journalists they know they're not
journalists in any way shape matter or
form they're blindsided by all their
failures and their prejudices and
political points of view this
impeachment sham is but the latest
example by the way it was never going to
be successful and today the president
pointed out the charade is now
completely and totally and utterly dead
and meaningless
take a look they should because it was
the hoax that's a very good question
should they expunge the impeachment in
the house they should because it was a
hoax it was a total political hoax yep
this latest impeachment hoax might now
be in the rearview mirror but the lying
the smears the besmirch bent the
conspiracy theories they never end just
today the president scored a massive
victory in the courts we have a
three-judge panel unanimously throwing
out a frivolous lawsuit brought by more
than 200 Democratic members of Congress
they lost again presidents not sick of
winning the suit alleged the president
was improperly profiting from his time
in the White House he actually loses his
money by working in the White House but
the court ruled lawmakers didn't have
any legal standing to proceed with their
claims and meanwhile rage-filled
delusional Democratic lawmakers and now
pressing forward with a variety of
frivolous investigations more
investigations endless investigations
more conspiracy theories more talk
already of impeachment against the
president a brand new effort to subpoena
john bolton here we go again this is not
over now there is one way i have figure
now you can end all of this the nonstop
lying the smearing the slander the
besmirching conspiracy theories witch
hunts the hoax is one way you can do it
in 270 days you will be the ultimate
jury and by the way you don't ever have
to waste your time watching any fake
news in the future you can just turn
that tune them out like most people are
the way to stop this from ever happening
again and continuing in 270 days you
will be the ultimate jury you get to
take back control of your country now if
you like President Trump and you'd like
to see and be able to work with a little
bit of peace and not having this these
constant you know threats hanging over
his head 24 hours a day every day of the
week
what would you vote for him you might
want to vote for Republican congressman
and Republican senators - the do-nothing
Democrats do you really think they
deserve your trust and by the way it's
now more clear than ever that the Trump
agenda as we saw on Tuesday night a
massive success despite the never-ending
non-stop radical resistance our economy
is breaking record after record and
booming January jobs numbers get that
beat all expectations yet again a
whopping 225,000 new jobs added even the
New York Times they were forced to admit
wages for African Americans is on the
rise after a decade of stagnation that
would be under Biden Obama today
President Trump celebrated America's
undeniable economic success let's take a
look this morning the brand new jobs
numbers came in we smashed expectations
and created 225,000 new jobs last month
[Applause]
225,000 they were thinking maybe a
hundred maybe 105 I was watching all the
geniuses this morning on television what
do you think it's gotta be it's gonna be
110 225 pretty good right 225,000 for
last month
that's only last
that's 225,000 new jobs for our American
family how great is that a booming
economy only one part of the successful
Trump agenda will scroll it for you
take a look we've been the only show on
TV apparently that ever does it but also
under this commander in chief the Isis
Caliphate has been destroyed utterly
utterly decimated Oh Isis leader al
Baghdady and his top lieutenants they're
all dead
Iran's top terrorists in number one
state-sponsored terror led by this guy
Soleimani he's dead too and now the
White House has confirmed that al
Qaeda's top leader in Yemen was killed
in a u.s. airstrike ordered by President
Trump over the past three years this
president has been an effective leader
by every measure the State of the Union
well is remarkably strong and the same
cannot be said for the Democratic Party
well look at their very first caucus an
utter complete disaster you want to
trust the government to them and they
couldn't even run a caucus in Iowa it
has taken them with the entire week to
count a few thousand votes and the
results are still riddled with errors
and inconsistencies and nobody believes
them anyway meanwhile a multi-front
civil war is erupting inside the
Democratic Party this is getting
entertaining according to a political
report Elizabeth Warren supporters they
are now accusing mayor Peabody judge of
white male privilege for declaring
victory in Iowa and both Warren and
mayor Pete they're losing to socialist
Bernie Sanders in a new morning console
poll and of course the DNC is now
looking for new ways well to rig the
primary election against Bernie yet
again remember Donna Brazile she made
the phone calls she was upset she didn't
want to make it yeah they rigged it
against Bernie the first time now it
looks like they're trying to do it again
his campaign is accusing the Democratic
Party of changing the rules which they
did to allow Mike Bloomberg into future
debates without meeting fundraising
requirements you know like 250,000
unique donors Bloomberg Worthen what
estimated 55 billion dollars well he's
planning on spending more than a billion
to buy the Democratic nomination now his
campaign is facing today you can't make
this up Pledger
some charges a matter of fact eight
separate instances the intercept first
reported that passages in at least eight
of Bloomberg's policy proposals were
directly copied from various media
outlets including fake news CNN Time
magazine CBS of course he'd be in
alignment with the most liberal news
organizations in the country guess
there's one thing money doesn't buy in
that's honesty and I guess he just
figures well I'll just take what they
have I don't know what I really believe
I'll say whatever I need to say our
democratic voter I think I'd feel very
discouraged about now the party is in
complete disarray the candidates are
weak they are radical they are
uninspiring the president's agenda is a
massive success and in 270 days it will
be the American people that will decide
whether we continue peace and prosperity
and that means economic success and that
means safety and security of our country
or do we want to turn it over to the
Democrats well we did have the Obama
years we did drop 150 billion in cash
you know the currency and the tarmacs
of mullahs in Iran that chant death to
America we did after eight years of
Biden Obama have 13 million more
Americans on food stamps 8 million more
on poverty in the lowest labor
participation rate since the 70s and
yeah Obama Biden accumulated more debt
than all 43 presidents before them
combined by the way now they want to
take it into a deeper socialist hellhole